[Music]
Nicki Minaj is back in a big way and
gracing the July 2018 cover of Elle
magazine inside the mag the rapper
shares she's had more personal growth in
the past six months then she's had in
the last eight years I feel like I'm the
king of the world
something she owes to being single for
the first time since she was 15 years
old quote as soon as I realized that I
could actually live and breathe and eat
and sleep and walk and talk without
having a boyfriend something clicked in
me
for the 35 year old being single makes
her feel strong and powerful the fact
that I am a young woman who doesn't need
a man for money
I don't need a man for a job I don't
have those pressures I get up when I
want shop when I want the
grammy-nominated rapper also opened up
about her ex boyfriend Meek Mill who at
the time of the interview was still
incarcerated for violating his probation
I know that when I went there pleading
for his freedom I know that the judge
spoke to me and was very sweet and
maternal and we both cried in her
chambers and she gave him another chance
in April Mill was released on bail after
the Pennsylvania Supreme Court ordered
his immediate release
[Music]
[Applause]